and um i lived in croydon and um
obviously croydon isn't exactly nice now
but it was even worse back then so um me
and my siblings were walking back from
school
and these two guys were fighting
one girl from the local secondary school
tried to get involved and try to get in
between the two guys
i turn around
um to look at my sister turn back around
the girl's ear is in her hand and
there's blood everywhere
yeah because obviously one of the guys
got a knife out and tried to do
whatever and
she ended up with half an ear cut off
girls that do that i did not know what
they're doing but hey that can't be me
it could never be me
have you seen that what's that porn
star's name uh a very big excuse me
cornstar
uh very big corn star uh
that her fiance or husband was a
some sort of fighter and he beat the
crap out of her he's in jail now for
life
wow
what's that cornstar's name
anyway you don't know that case
no well it's a big case it doesn't
surprise me yeah he's been like
a mixed martial artist or something yeah
like a professional like fighter or
something and beat the crap out of her
sounds like you had a lot of attention
to get off his chest i think she was
filming
she was filming something and then they
were doing it at her place and then he
found them together you know he knew she
was a corn star
but he got jealous i don't know i don't
know what happened
okay yeah i was never going to work
don't you guys feel like um will smith
got off lightly for putting his hand on
the map
it's not just women that sort of get
away with that what if what if chris was
a woman did you think he would have got
in the way of it
no
but there was no meaning a woman if if
if chris rock was a woman would will
smith have gotten away with it no no so
i think it shows you dance
don't
regard uh violence on men the same way
they regard violence on women
men are seen as expendable in society
where women women are seen as more
valuable than men
that's why they have been to all the
hard jobs that's why that's why women
get slapped on the wrist for everything
they can sleep with a minor and they get
out of it they can
hit a man and get out of it whenever
it's against men like they just get out
of it
you know i used to get hit on by this
uh colleague of mine
and i told people i told my my singing
teacher and she's like oh i bet you love
it and every time every time we tell
someone like come on man's fine i bet
you love the attention
no not really
yeah i've had a similar experience where
i got essayed by this girl
and like she
obviously i i didn't want to hit her
because i was just like you know
um get off me but i don't want to hit
her or anything because i'm not trying
to go into something you'd be in trouble
exactly and then i remember i was
telling this guy at work and it was like
nah man you must have loved it i was
like
are you done
but that's the thing it's just seen as
like can i just add something to that
actually because i think a lot of the
time what tends to happen is when we
have these experiences where
men get essayed right and other men go
oh bet you loved it it's probably
because they haven't had any sexual
interactivity and so
they're projecting
what they would have felt in that
situation because they haven't been
touched in a while yeah i guess i
completely agree obviously
you know
i wasn't in any danger like i wasn't
gonna be hurt or die or anything but
it's not a good situation to be in it's
not a position especially when you don't
want to be in that position but yeah
we're just expected to you know take on
the channel or just enjoy it and take it
anecdotally how common do you guys think
um
essay is from women to men
and just anecdotally no
no no not no numbers just in your
personal experience is that something
that you know to be common i mean for me
personally um it's happened a lot whilst
it was at uni and a lot of my friends
happened to them too
um
but i don't know about in
general you know
i guess it depends on how you define it
um yeah
if you would uh call it
unwanted sexual advances i'm sorry uh is
that one of those terms i need you could
say that that's fine this time unwanted
advances
i think
anyone who is of an age to where they're
attractive are going to get advances
some of them are going to be from people
you want some of them people you don't
want
men and women both
nobody wants to be you know approached
by them
and and they come up hey come on come
over my house no nobody wants it
but you don't want whale sightings
you know unless you're into whales
you know
whales wealthy loving too but uh you
know yeah and exactly and some sometimes
it's gonna you know you're not gonna
feel it and
no means no
right and that's not just a woman thing
that no means no men need to set their
boundaries too that's part of what makes
us men we set our boundaries and if
anybody crosses it you're going to feel
the consequences period i think what
happens more often is that women it's
not really their weapon they make rumors
though that's what i've noticed they
make a lot of rumors girls like do that
like uh grape rumors accusations and all
that stuff that happens very very often
it's just not exactly stories
no
that's actually
i've heard so many horror stories from
girls i just don't believe them all
there's too many girls that like
come like that when i'm interviewing
will say this all this stuff happened to
them the worst horror story ever but
they don't press charges yes if this
happened why wouldn't you press charges
that doesn't make sense unless you think
you don't have evidence and maybe you're
not telling the truth like i know i know
it's difficult to do but like
it just doesn't
it's too i hear it too much and i don't
think that many men are out there just
graping everybody doesn't make sense
like there's something they're not
adding there's some detail that's
important to the story
i don't think anybody that's been a
victim
that doesn't want
a person to victimize them to pay
i think there are some cases where
a victim can be in a situation is afraid
of the consequence by bringing that to
the attention maybe they still live in
the home
of their abuser
so maybe they're afraid if i complain to
the police tomorrow i'm getting beat
there's that but that's still the small
ask every one of those people if they
want that person to be thrown in prison
and they're going to say yes i think the
majority of these people that personally
that
make the accusation
and have no intention of fulfilling are
either telling a story that they heard a
story that they saw on tv a story they
wished happened so they could have
something to talk about
i i do think like the way like society
is now i feel like it is the best of
like worse options so obviously it's not
great because there are women that you
know exaggerate and lie and sort of the
power is with the women but i've lived
like because i went to secondary school
in nigeria and like in nigeria it's like
a completely different culture i can't
say don't won't come for me i can't say
how it is right now
um but when i was there like you'd be
hara i would be harassed constantly by
men and the thing is as well in that
society women are blamed so like it
instead of actually seeing why has this
man done this they're gonna say but what
were you wearing what were you doing to
to bring that on and so like it's a lot
worse in those kind of societies where i
can really appreciate here where even
though yes it's never there's never
going to be complete equality so even
though there are um it can be really
terrible for men but at the same time i
do feel like this is the best best of
both worlds do you think